tenemos la gráfica de una función efe
efe de x justo aquí que es está pintada
en azul y queremos pensar en el límite
de la función cuando x tiende a 3 muy
bien entonces lo que vamos a hacer para
tratar de resolver este problema es
pensar aquellos valores de x que son más
grandes que 3 y nos vamos aproximando
por la derecha y los que son más chicos
que 3 entonces primero pensemos por
ejemplo qué pasa con el límite de
nuestra función f x cuando x tiende a 3
pero por la izquierda ok
bueno quizás debería pintar bien aquí un
menos este signo menos que pongo arriba
del 3 significa que nos vamos a estar
aproximando al 3 por este lado del lado
izquierdo muy bien para valores más
chicos que 3 entonces por ejemplo si
estamos nosotros aquí en no sé quizás
nos aproximamos primero por 1
vemos que la función toma un valor como
de 5.5 o algo así si vamos al
2 puede que bueno algo muy similar a lo
mejor si ya estamos en 2.5 ahora toma
valor de 5 y si nos aproximamos todavía
más nos damos cuenta de que nos
aproximamos a un valor y que puedo
presumir que es el 4 muy bien entonces
realmente este real se parece mucho a
que se aproxima a 4 por el lado
izquierdo ahora bien qué pasa si
consideramos el límite de nuestra
función f x pero ahora la x tiende a 3
por el lado derecho es decir por los
valores más grandes que 3 por ejemplo si
vale 5 pues estaremos a esta altura si
vale 4 éste estamos como en 2.5 más o
menos si ahora estamos en 4.5 a lo mejor
vale 2 algo así pero el chiste es que
nos vamos aproximando a este otro valor
que en realidad vale 1 muy bien entonces
este valor de arriba era 4 mientras que
si nos aproximamos por la derecha por
estos números más grandes que 3
a un valor de 1 entonces para que exista
este límite el límite de la función
cuando x tiende a 3 debe ser igual tanto
el límite por la izquierda como el
límite por la derecha pero en este caso
son distintos claramente uno está más
arriba que el otro entonces este límite
no existe no existe entonces sólo
existiría si hubiéramos obtenido el
mismo valor en estos dos límites
laterales y ese sería el límite de la
función pero claramente no lo estamos
obteniendo